so uh uh it depends if we are just
starting with our uh product uh and we
don't have the expertise uh or or the
affordability I'll say um to have so
much of resources that will learn
kubernetes that will uh manage those
clusters because e Cas you have to
manage the Clusters you have to manage e
case versions uh you have to learn how
to implement all those things and it
could be a bit difficult but like if you
have a uh if you if you're having a
startup and if you just want to get
started without um all those hurdles
then you can just start with a monolith
application and also if your
architecture does not require to be that
complex then it's better to go with
monolith but if you want flexibility and
much configuration management and all
then it's better to go with the
container based system like eks or ECS